okay the time being 10 I'm going to
convene this meeting of the commission
on worldwide combined reporting for the
uh unitary businesses under the business
profit
tax
um we
have a draft of the Minority Report that
we received last week from
representative shamberg
advocating uh in
favor of moving to the worldwide
combined reporting and uh representative
shamberg as we knew will not be here
today um and he has uh told us that he
is likely to make revisions to that uh
draft so I'm sure we'll have an updated
version from him when we meet next
Monday
um I've circulated uh to the members a
draft of the report that goes so far as
uh laying out the process and procedure
that we've been through so
far and the testimony and the record uh
reciting what we've heard from those
who've come before
us and uh I thought when I began
drafting that that it might be more
brief uh but it turns out you can't be
very cursory about these heavily nuanced
um specific positions so it is actually
a pretty full-bodied
um synopsis of the actual position of
each um each of our expert
Witnesses um so
so we will discuss
that the we also have um the document
prepared by our two members Kevin
Kennedy and Matt
Foley which elaborates on the uh outline
that they put before us last week into
more of a a narrative and uh I know that
I've just uh I'm just seeing that uh for
the first time as we convene
um so I think that uh we should look at
the Kennedy Foley draft
section as the basis for the
findings um segment of our
report and during the coming week we can
flush out elaborate uh on any of the
things that are in that and see whether
it covered the
Waterfront so
the progression of the
report U we've had a bit of a bumpy
start and that's laid
out we've had a very diverse uh set of
uh participate participants and comments
and I believe that that is well laid out
in the finding in in the U testimony
record
section but we may want to add a little
bit more in regards to some of the
written submissions we've received it's
very thorough at this moment
in terms of everybody who appeared
before
us
um and then I think the
findings should be as much as possible
uh statements of fact as we understand
them pros and cons the report is a very
balanced document I believe through
those sections doesn't take a stance for
example in the synopsis of testimony uh
there's no commentary from the chair or
from the members it's just trying to in
a very even way um State what their
position was so we'll then need uh to
boil down our findings with
recommendations and uh those are not yet
prepared as of today but I would say we
work on drafting the recommendations
during the week and when we meet next
Monday
morning uh I'd like to conclude the
report as much as possible there might
be some eyes to do and teas to cross
after we leave next
Monday so you'll be getting the things
that I'm talking about early in this
week so that it's not a uh you know
Sunday night Monday morning U
surprise okay so we have we know that
representative shamberg will not be with
us today and Matt Foley advised he'll be
delayed to 10:30 I'd like to take any
questions or comments and then suggest
perhaps we just recess briefly while we
wait for Matt Foy will give us a chance
to read what's been put in front of us
this
morning okay any comments or
questions okay the commission is in
recess till the call of the chair
approximately at
10:30
e
okay thank you uh as Mr fol has joined
us uh we have our Quorum uh this is a
official meeting of the commission on
worldwide combined reporting um drafting
in progress up to this date uh has been
uh is not publicly disseminated but the
drafts as of this date that are being
considered by a quarum of the committee
are now public documents and extra
copies have been laid out on the
table before we get into the substance I
just want to uh observe that
uh representative shamberg has prepared
minutes for both the October 10th and
October 17th meetings as he's not here
and I see a couple of small revisions
I'd like to suggest we'll wait till we
meet next week at which point we'll look
at all of the minutes of the last
several meetings including today's and
we'll adopt minutes anticipating that
next Monday is our last
meeting um and I'm expecting that Mr
Kennedy is going to be unable to attend
next Monday at this time I'm won to okay
but the the remaining six uh I'm
expecting all of us to be here so we'll
have the necessary Quorum and in
representative Schamberg's absence uh
representative Olie has graciously
agreed to uh uh keep the record of
attendance and prepare
minutes
so I'm very pleased
that uh I think the pieces are are
fitting together and we're seeing what
this is going to look like uh as I said
uh when I opened and uh I'm going to
repeat this just briefly for Mr Foley's
benefit the draft that I've
prepared goes so far as to lay out the
process and
procedures and to provide a pretty
thorough uh granular synopsis of the
testimony and record of all of the
experts who appeared before us either in
person or via video
link and that includes
also
um the uh testimony we received a year
ago so I think that section is virtually
complete I think the only addition that
I'm considering adding to it is with
there's been quite quite a bit of
discussion of the itep study and the tax
found foundation's
rebuttal and if everybody else agrees
even though they neither appeared in
front of us we have their reports
they've um uh had
a focus in our conversations and I think
it would be good to include those in the
synopsis of the record the rest of the
things that we have you know received or
received links to studies uh things that
are online court cases etc etc will not
be
described in the uh record uh section
but we have a very extensive
bibliography that Gen 4 has prepared for
us and I think everyone's seen that so
it's a anybody who's coming back at this
issue at a later date doing research uh
has a very extensive uh guide of
resources um so to does everybody agree
that it makes sense to include a brief
synopsis of the itep estimate and the
tax Foundation rebot okay I will do
that so I think that uh that will be
appending that that will go into the uh
section of testimony and
record um as additional documents that
were carefully reviewed by the
commission added as agenda I see we
could do that we could have them as
attachments any objection to that okay
agreed um let me just make a note of
that
all right so again the purpose of the uh
testimoni and record is to be fair and
balanced to to make an accurate
description of what we heard so please
as you read this more carefully during
the coming week if you think there's
anything there that's misstated
mischaracterized out of balance let me
know that
um and uh we'll do any massaging that we
uh that we believe is
necessary I don't I think if you're
going to send a comment to me copy the
other members but I don't anticipate a
lot of discussion via email uh which is
not a noticed meeting just rather you
know here's what I've seen and then let
me evaluate it and if there's questions
we can discuss it next
Monday
uh again I I know you've only gotten
this last evening or in some cases this
morning and have had Fairly scant
opportunity to look at it but is there
anything that anybody wants to bring up
at this
point about the draft on testimony and
record yes Mr
Wong thank you chair uh just a quick
observation um on page five the uh first
paragraph the second last
line onto the right so it says even the
rate on BPT and then Z 0 I'm not sure if
that was um typo or something like that
I'm not sure that is definitely a typo
and and I will read it closely and clean
it up all right thank
you good catch thank you that's exactly
I need eagle
eyes any other observations at this
point right so please do not hold back
during the week and the earlier in the
week you can get me your comments uh the
better and I'll try to incorporate
things rapidly as I receive
them okay so let's move on to the
findings and
recommendations I'm going to divide
findings and recommendations so the
caption that you see on page seven of
the draft
report uh comes from a uh a template
that Gen 4 provided me this next section
will be
findings and I think the findings should
be as close as possible to a declarative
statements of what we all um effectively
agree to that doesn't mean that there
couldn't be a 61 divide of opinion but
it speaks for the Commission in other
words and I think that uh
what Mr Kennedy and Mr Foley have put
forward is a
fantastic um foundation for the findings
we can elaborate on it massage on it a
little bit but that I think is something
that we should uh discuss next so what
you don't so you take the portion I've
drafted the portion that they have
drafted and that brings us I think all
the way through a factual summary of
everything we've heard and concluded
what that then
leaves is the question is there any
analysis and explanation that is more
opinion based and I think there might be
a bit of
that but I don't have I want to get home
sit down at my computer and think a
little bit more about what if anything
needs explanation to
support the commission's ultimate
recommendation
and then the recommendation we will take
a
position for or against advancing
worldwide combined reporting right I
would just um say that uh yes do we need
to take a position saying that or or is
this is the charge of the commission
more to analyze and provide uh
options um with
a
determination as to what
the balances not recommend worldwide not
oppose worldwide but just say this is
what's going to happen if you do this
and we don't know what's going to happen
if you do
that okay that's an excellent question
and I think that
um the answer is that that is certainly
an option and I think we'll be in a
position to decide whether that's the
path we want to take next Monday um
here's here's my thoughts on uh
representative oler's
question it depends what we believe
right our charge is to weighs weigh the
advantages and the
disadvantages but there will be a
Minority Report that is clearly
advocating that the New Hampshire
legislature adopt worldwide combined
reporting so the question for the six of
us is do we agree with that or do we
disagree with that if we disagree with
it then our
recommendation I think is likely to come
down with a firm statement that we think
it is not advisable to go forward what
what this commission has not been
charged to do has not taken testimony to
do and is not prepared to do is to
recommend some alternative so we're not
going to end up up with a report that
says instead of worldwide combined
reporting let's you know I don't adopt
pillar one and pillar two is proposed by
the oecd or what have you all right
we're either going to
say yes we recommend going forward with
Worldwide combined reporting or no we
don't so I think the
recommendation has to take a
position at the
least whether it is appropriate at this
time for the New Hampshire legislature
to move ahead or
not um I would also I this is a good
moment to um ask Mr
Wong um we were having a sidebar
conversation before the meeting
[Music]
began
um
and you have to ask yourself even if
even if the commission recommended in
favor
of implementing worldwide combined
reporting do we have a vehicle yet that
would implement it adequately so for
example
hb21 will come before the Ways and Means
Committee within the next two three
weeks um and will be decided it's going
to be decided either uh OTP itl or
interim study so you would have to ask
yourself not just whether you think
worldwide combined report in is a good
move and appropriate but also whether
hp21 is
drafted actually does what's necessary
and Mr Juan could you just elaborate on
what you think such a bill would have to
include in order to prepare the Dr for
implementation right so um so just to re
reiterate the dr's position we are
neutral on whether um the state takes up
legislation to go proceed with uh forde
combine reporting or to uh remain as a
water AG um filing position uh however
it it plays out the Dr would continue to
uh try to implement the tax uh New
Hampshire's tax laws uh in terms of uh
if there is a motion to move ahead with
Worldwide combining filing reporting as
it is current laws are written or
designed for waterers Edge for fing and
uh we definitely would need I think we
definitely would need additional
guidance or new legislation in terms of
uh redrafting certain parts of uh uh the
BPT statute to incorporate worldwide
filing um because right now all most of
the most if not all definitions is
related to worldwide uh sorry to uh
waterers Edge and then that's the
taxation of uh foreign dividends and um
um that kind of thing so all that
probably will have to be changed um and
and be considered how best to
um to to um I guess redraft it just to
to re-engineer for worldwide combined
filing
purposes so how to define a unitary
group for example exactly one of those
things would be uh the definition of
unitary and undoubtedly others and I
would just uh comment that if one looks
at um
hb21 thought I had it there in front of
me uh it it's probably 80% preperatory
language statements of purpose and uh
intent uh a rationale for why it would
be you know a good a good bill when you
get to the guts of the implementing uh
portion of the bill it's then a series
of repeals and then it's one very brief
statement that BAS basically says go
Implement worldwide combined reporting
so what what Mr Wong is saying is even
if you were in favor of that
bill you would want it elaborated so
that the legislature gives guidance
right prior to rul making Authority yes
um to implement the flush it out yeah
okay important point so representative
Olie did we uh come to a balanced
conclusion on your
question
proba okay and you know hey if if we uh
find ourselves in a very ambiguous place
then the the recommendation might
Express something that's ambiguous if we
find that we're pretty much in unison
and that we believe it is not a good
idea for the state to proceed then I
think we should state that unequivocably
okay um Miss Mr Foley and Mr Kennedy um
can you walk us through I've just had a
chance to read this I'm very impressed I
I like the structure and the
approach
um but why don't I turn it over to you
and
uh let you lead that
discussion Matt I've got him right here
oh no I passed mine
off
yes Mr Kennedy thank you uh Mr
chairman in terms of the comments you
just made about what it is we're coming
back with um I brought up the um house
bill I think it was 102 from 22 which
established this commission um just to
see was there actually what the
requirements were I don't know if you
had that with you um and it it seems to
me that that the guidance is is pretty
ambiguous meaning that it just for
clarity it seems to me it just says we
just have to report our findings back it
doesn't necessarily say we make
recommendations um it doesn't
necessarily say you know we issue this
type of report or that type of report so
I just want to be clear that relative to
what we're actually required to do under
this bill or law um is simply to report
back and the form of that report or the
content um um presumably is is is not
concrete or set as to what what its
content needs to be would you agree I
think that's absolutely correct and to
be more
specific uh
12 colon 2 Roman numeral 3 says we shall
study the advantages and disadvantages
for the state economy and revenues of
replacement of the current Waters Edge
method by the worldwide combined report
warning method M satisfied that we've
done that and Roman umal
5 uh says a final report of its findings
and any recommendations for proposed
legislation honor before November 1st so
you're correct uh it's at the discretion
of the
commission it would make a difference if
we found that we uh you know had six
voices uh in unison and only one
uh dissenting
view or
here um versus whether you know we may
have several people who feel firmly that
uh that there should be a recommendation
against and several who are in a more
neutral or nuanced position we can
articulate that if that's the case I
think recommendations can include some
indication of how strong the support was
so I think we'll we'll have a feel for
that next Monday but not probably today
okay thank you um relative to
recommendations um and again I think
this is more as we move through this
week um potentially there is additional
studies that could be done down the road
once information is made available to
the Dr assuming the Dr is given
direction to study things like
International reporting and the guilty
and things like that would that be
something we would want to recommend or
entertain or include in the report or is
that just kind of beyond the scope of of
what this committee is out to do well
we're all freethinkers and I and I would
encourage freethinking so please by all
means as you think about this earlier in
the week is
better any proposed recommendations that
any individual member wants to uh lob
over the side I would be very
welcomed um and I I think that the idea
that a recommendation
about future study or about an
alternative or about something other
than just yes or no uh could be very
helpful so if you could fashion a draft
recommendation uh along line as you're
thinking um that would be great thank
you
okay Mr
Foy
uh sure so just kind of walk through
this I assume is the intention chair
yeah and just level or yeah what what I
was thinking is you've done a great
job of breaking this into four into into
segments generally accepted
considerations where there is a
consensus another section potential
mitigating
factors
excellent and then further items in
support and against the pros and the
cons which you've
separated what I think you might do
is take us one by one through the
numbered
statement without the narrative that
follows it and let's just stop and pause
on each one of them and make sure we
agree absolutely yeah and so this is
just an expansion of the bullet point
list that we went through when was our
last meeting two weeks ago
everyday's blending last week GH Yeah
Tuesday that's right yeah and thank you
very much for we had a tax deadline I
I'm feeling it now uh thank you for
developing it into a narrative yes yes
and so um so these should be familiar um
there is obviously more color so
generally accepted considerations the
first one um constitutionally moving to
worldwide reporting should be allowed
okay we can just stop there
um the
the
only passage that I've drafted already
in the findings is one specifically that
reviews the Constitutional and I would
simply suggest that we take what I've
drafted and plug it right in there as
the narrative that supports that
statement and I would make one other
suggestion
um constitutionally moving to worldwide
reporting should be allowed I just want
to change the phrasing so that that
doesn't sound should be allowed sounds
like an endorsement what I think I'd
like to say
is um moving to worldwide
reporting would have no constitutional
barriers
does that make sense absolutely so we're
just simply saying there's nothing that
bars action on a constitutional
level all right right um the second
generally accepted consideration
transfer pricing exists um it's a very
simple overview of transfer pricing here
um so hopefully that provides some
context without going into hundreds of
pages of
explanations I think it's very succinct
and well put yeah Jordan actually me
representative Valerie yeah uh the first
question you just answered the second
question I I mentioned earlier to Mr
Kennedy um we're using two different
terms to discuss the same item and we
had need to find either a common
terminology or or something to describe
what what we're talking about you're
talking about price transfer it's really
not price transfer but although that may
be the terminology used um in in the
jargon if you will within the CPA
language where and my friend is going to
use transfer wealth or uh profit taking
or profit hiding or some other type of
language that that uh he uses so I think
we need to have a common terminology
that it's merely the transfer of funds
from one entity to another for whatever
purpose whether it's to hide it from
taxation legally uh or whether it's to
help build something else up I I I I
think that distinction needs to be made
when we're describing what does take
place we not we're not creating the um
appearance that this is
legal um tax evasion which is you know
that's the second American P so we don't
want to create a
pejorative yes um implication that
transfer pricing is somehow inherently
bad I think transfer pricing is in fact
a term of art that is used by the tax
authorities by accountants and
universally uh does describe what we're
talking about um and Jordan if you see
other examples again whether you bring
them up this morning which would be
great or whether you uh um shoot a out
in an email it it would
be General word smithing for sure and if
you have specific uh something that uh
um you know gives you reservations
please point it out yeah and and what
we've tried transfer pricing itself is
just a terminology used to describe
related party transfers and the pric is
you know ascribed there too so that
whether it's abusive or not is a second
conversation that is just the accounting
process for related party transfers and
so I understand what you're saying so
what we've try to do here is to the
extent that there is seemed to be an
abuse we've tried to say abuse right so
we've we've put abusive transfer pricing
and that's the next bullet where it
creates an uneven playing field and I
would just recommend transfer pricing
itself is the terminology and
phraseology used globally you know for
related party transfers um and
transactions from there where we we find
bad parties right you know maybe taking
legal or unlegal abusive positions I
think we should just classify as such as
that's the risk so this is this is a
very good discussion it illustrates the
value of having uh qualified CPAs on the
commission and uh taking a lead in
drafting this portion there is a
difference between
the testimony
records where I'm attempting to recount
what individual presenters
said and in many cases they may have
said something in fact intending you
know that it's
pejorative um but I think in this
section of the
report uh the fact that we're grounded
in neutral terminology and uh the
experience of accountants who practice
in the area is valuable this should be a
neutral
section yes Mr Kennedy um if I may
because Mr shar's not here I think we're
we referring to transfer pricing and
then abusive transfer pricing um and of
course the abusive transfer pricing is
just something that the US government or
some government agency would take uh
issue with in terms of transfer pricing
we're talking about items that are
acceptable or allowable under the law
and the taxing rules however um what
worldwide reporting would do would
address more the transfer pricing versus
the abusive transfer pricing which is to
say that even though it's allowed and
legal and um uh provided for under the
uh code and the
regulations that the transfer pricing
still has a mechanism with which
rightfully so funds are transferred to a
lower taxing jurisdiction because of the
use of of patents or trademarks or what
have you and that the worldwide
reporting would essentially remove that
function of allowable transfer pricing
and I'm just trying to make sure that it
there's a distinction that um this
worldwide reporting is not really
looking to um look at abusive transfer
pricing but to look at transfer pricing
entire it effectively neutralizes any
intra affiliate transfer by pooling them
um that's a valuable explanation you
might want to jot that down and
incorporate it can I get a recording of
today's meeting and I'll just we are
recorded again so the answer is yes on
the YouTube um by the way for anybody
who's not familiar with it because we're
not all legislators but if you go to the
uh open page of the general Court's
website and you scroll all the way to
the bottom in the band at the bottom
you'll see house streaming Senate
streaming if you click on house
streaming it brings up the YouTube
channel for the general
court and um that can sometimes be a
little obscure I find but you have to go
up to the top menu and hit at home to
get the most recent hearings and this
will be viewable as soon as this
evening um I I I would say further you
know profit shifting right now now we're
moving into another term which is
suggesting a
motive for the transfer
pricing and you know I think that
there's actually another Nugget In what
you were just saying and that is that
The Proposal of worldwide combined
reporting is arguably over
broad relative to its Target which is
abusive practices and interestingly
that's what the whole arms length
guidelines and regulations in the
separate accounting is all about it's
about zeroing in on
unjustifiable transfer pricing so it is
a weakness in the worldwide combined
reporting that it's over
Brad okay back to Mr
Foley oh representative thank you yeah
that brings up two points i' really do
like your the last phraseology that with
that and discussion and explanation uh
that was that was concise um I just
remind remind the people that are going
to use
this some of them have little to know
economic knowledge I mean as far as
having taken any uh serious economic
courses um they do have e economic
Knowledge from whatever background they
are but the except from Dr homy uh who's
got quite a bit of it but
um when we talk about one phrase and uh
Mr chair just uh Terry you just brought
it out uh there's a diff there's three
differences there one is profit taking
one is abusive uh uh transfer pricing
and one is uh necessary transferred
pricing for the uh operation of the U
the business I've mentioned this several
times during the discussion uh you have
a large corporation and it needs extra
money over here that's not abusive
that's just taking money from where
because money is fungible moving it from
point A to point B I think that needs to
be clear in in uh that there are two
different types of transfer pricing
um and we and on the uh the general side
of the discussion rather than using a
bunch of different language we need to
use the same phrase so that we know that
we're talking about the same
action on both neutral side the
legislative side and the opposition side
that tell that I think Tom ought to
uh representing shamberg ought to be
made aware that that's the the goal is
to use the same language
everywhere uh so that when he's talking
about something he he uses the same
language that we're talking about it so
we don't wind up with different words
saying the same
thing I'm okay these are very valid
points I think to um see what you are
saying through into the draft will
require some
specific at its suggestions um I think
we're all mindful of this but by all
means if you catch some of these things
that uh you think
are it's a valuable comment um one of
the things that I want to be mindful of
is that representative shamberg has made
it clear he is going to file a Minority
Report recommending worldwide combined
reporting I've read his
draft and I don't want to Tamper with it
I think it's his expression of what he
believes um the fact is it's very
passionate and there are things that he
says that I don't personally believe can
be backed up or maybe are a bit
overstated or a bit argumentative or a
bit shrill but I don't know that I want
to um we could suggest to him how he
might temper something but it's his
document
okay and and so the the third one uh
third bullet here and I I do think it's
attempting to address your concerns
um representative rry is transfer
pricing exists and maybe we can
emphasize the point that it's a
necessary business multinational it's a
requirement it's not it's not good bad
or indifferent it's a requirement in an
integrated vertical business so there's
no choice you know an analogy occurred
to me during this past week and that is
franchises correct so a franchise is
very much of an arms length relationship
you have a corporate parent and you have
a FR franchisee who has uh uh qualified
and made an investment and entered into
a contractual relationship if I own 14
Subways and I'm dealing with the parent
Corporation there will be a whole set of
understandings about how much I have to
contribute for marketing how much I have
to contribute for brand recognition how
much I have to contribute for all kinds
of things this these are
examples of how you wouldn't necessarily
call that an affiliate but in a
franchise arms length relationship you
have the very same kinds of transfers
it's just customary business practice to
share Investments made on behalf of your
coop operating
partners and so that that is the the
second bullet just kind of acknowledging
it exists and again maybe we can
emphasize that it's a requirement it's a
need it's not an option and and the
third one is to acknowledge the fact
that there is um you know we say
perceived because you know who are we to
you know full full-heartedly upon um
abusive transfer
pricing uh practices out there that
result in and um you know truly uh
trying to uh take advantage of uh kind
of misalignments in the tax code right
it's been the old play where they can
you can shift profits to low tax or no
tax
jurisdictions um and then um also kind
of
acknowledging uh the efforts to curb
that activity all right so that's that's
what the third part takes address of in
in we do also kind of Prelude into into
the fourth part which is the state uh
and I can pause after this but does tax
foreign income um already generated by
businesses subject to the business
profits
tax um these would be multinationals
with foreign subsidiary investments in
foreign subsidiaries so this is not your
foreign entity with us subsidiaries just
to highlight that fact I know that is a
distinction we're going to make in The
Wider
report um but it does talk through kind
of the the two instances when foreign
Dividends are received um or when these
deemed foreign dividend rules um arise
from a US federal tax perspective and
included in the tax
base all right so that's number four I
thought that was excellent and then
number five um just you know one of the
things we were assigned with here is um
the revenue impact of the change that's
one of the things we were charged with
studying um and as we all no one
appreciate it's it's unknown good bad
and different um and just kind of
highlighted the the three points which
are all the points but the three points
on making that determination the current
tax a foreign income the expansion in
the tax base which would be unknown
unknowable probably and then the impact
on the apportionment
Factor um which would impact
that I think the Dr would fully stand
behind that statement that it's
impossible to
estimate that is correct we currently do
not collect all the um the worldwide um
information to make an estimate of of
what it would be if we would be
switching to worldwide and I think
that's probably um consistent with with
the other state reports or state studies
done by or the studies done by the other
states when they're contemplating over I
combine
fing that's an interesting observation I
would I would concur with that I hadn't
thought about it previously but uh in
reading the studies uh and and what I've
seen of Indiana Minnesota uh Maine and
Rhode Island four states that have
recently considered this within the last
half dozen years they may have had
submissions like we have
had um making estimates but in none of
those reports was there an estimate that
is cor I think that the state officials
behind those reports concluded that they
were um that there was no methodology
and no data that would support an
estimate right like Thee the I think the
latest report was from Maine and um the
main Revenue I think they were charged
with performing a study and they they
were according to the report that I read
uh they didn't were not able to come up
with uh definitive numbers uh for
estimation um I think that would be
consistent with with New Hampshire as
well um um because we just don't have
the data to to make that estimation um
and then I guess similarly with
um I think was was Minnesota that was um
mentioned in the tax Foundation
report where um you know they actually
adopted or modified numbers from the
iTab report versus having their own um
study I suppose their own analysis or
calculations yeah good thank
you uh we we shift from there I don't
know if there was any you know and I
know Kevin you went through those were
it for generally accepted considerations
I don't know if there's a desire to add
any more um well I think we should all
uh think about that as we digest this
during the week but I I was very
impressed with that choice of five uh
elements to hit and I think I'm going to
have to be in the weeds again before I
can even think whether there's
another and and then so for mitigating
factors you know the the one thing we
wanted to acknowledge well the two
things one is is the US federal tax
landscape um and how it has um
disincentivized to some extent the you
know potential abusive profit shifting
just with a lower federal tax rate um a
more encompassing anti- deferral
provision guilty everyone's favorite I'm
sure you guys are talking about it at
home at this point um and then also the
fact that the oecd beeps project which
has been going on for 10 years now uh
does continue and and again it is
targeting abusive transfer pricing
schemes amongst other
things um and so that that's really the
key mitigating factors as you know the
focus of this is abusive transfer
pricing um and out bounding of profits
um those are the ones we identified we
thought of going much further on this
but we didn't want to overwhelm on
mitigating factors
either do you think that any of the tax
developments within the state of New
Hampshire
itself would also constitute mitigating
factors let's say than development since
1986 I don't know what you think Kevin I
mean single sales would be the that's a
local right so it's not going to help
outside
um I guess I'd have to think about
it as a mitigating Factor it uh lo I
mean other than of course and it's
referenced later on the um uh taking the
guilty income and applying it to New
Hampshire taxation which isn't really a
mitigating factor in this report board
it's really the fact that it's one of
the uh um uh arguments against is that
New Hampshire already taxes it so we
didn't really put it in so much as a
mitigating Factor um other than that I
can't think of anything offand I think
that distinction makes good sense um you
are addressing New Hampshire's use of
guilty in the context in a different
context in a different in the context of
the fact that we are generating tax
revenue right not as so much as a
mitigating Factor is that that there's
already some taxation of of foreign
income by so here what you're basically
getting at when you say mitigating
measures is mitigating the
Temptation or desirability to use
transfer pricing in an abusive way yeah
mitigating elaborate that SL mitigating
transfer pricing in general um not
necessarily for New Hampshire but but
transfer because let let's tease that
out right so the so your point here is
that this segment is
mitigating the Temptation for
undesirable behavior on the tax
filer whereas there's a different
mitigation going on in the other group
and that is mitigating the impact on the
state of New
Hampshire's tax revenue right so for New
Hampshire to apply guilty income does
probably does not mitigate someone's
desire for transfer pricing uh activity
however the other items the fact that
the corporate rate is lower that these
other uh things were put into place to
tax foreign income means that companies
are no are less
um encouraged to do that because there
are these other mitigating factors that
says well we can bring we've already
been taxed on our dividend so we can
bring that back into the us because it's
already been taxed it's not going to get
taxed again they're already taxing us on
guilty so we can bring these things in
and those things though I'm not sure
there's any evidence to show this in
theory would reduce um the desire for
companies to have these perceived
abusive uh transfer pricing items the
fact that New Hampshire has guilty
probably doesn't have any sort of
influence in that regard so it's a it's
a valid a very I think a very
significant distinction let's just make
sure our captions make that
distinction so treating them separately
is the right thing to do and
why and and then we go into the for and
against
um uh discussion and in the four and you
know perhaps we should shoot a note to
um representative shamberg to just to
see if he he would have feedback here to
expand on it right I think that's only
fair and what we should do um is if I
understand is his position it is um it
would eliminate any perceived Advantage
received by multinational businesses due
to their transer pricing policies with
foreign related parties right so they
have the ability the
availability to undertake transfer
pricing um as I've said before they have
a requirement to undertake transfer
pricing um however it could be abusive
or perceived abusive and as a result
that would be mitigated through the
proposal so um I will shoot him a note
later today or tomorrow just to make
sure that at a minimum he reads that
paragraph so that if he would like to
bolster it in the neutral or at least
provide feedback now I've only seen this
uh in paper on arrival but did you say
it's already been circulated yeah we
sent an I sent an email hopefully it
came through this morning this morning
good so representative shamberg does
have it correct and and I would
anticipate it's very likely he'll sit
and watch the video of this meeting as
well well
respond um against these were the ones
that um we had identified here um again
change as needed enhance um States
removal of the worldwide combined method
in 1986 ensured that businesses with a
New Hampshire tax presence were treated
equally um this kind of pulls on the
thread that you had emphasized um
chairman in last week's
meeting um I trust your uh Position will
expand on that um yes definitely yeah
it's it's it's a very interesting thing
it's this is not effectively The
Proposal is not a return to what
happened in 81 to 886 that
by itself doesn't make it either good or
bad but in 81 to 86 the uneven
enforcement created exactly the kind of
e of inequity that for example Mr gar
highlighted um and uh the move to W's
hedge was an effort to end that kind of
discrimination between uh us-based
multinationals and foreign-based so it's
then interesting to see that
even the water's edge in in some
people's minds um may be fundamentally
flawed because it's
inequitable we'll yes we'll address that
all right um the second one I I think is
one that we're all conscious of but New
Hampshire would be an outlier and that
the only true mandatory worldwide is for
oil and gas producers in Alaska every
other state is elective um
um third um potential decrease in
foreign direct investment in New
Hampshire business Community um you know
emphasis on potential no one would
know uh whether that would occur uh but
that has been highlighted and
communicated to us
um notable increase in administrative
and compliance burden on businesses tax
practitioners in New Hampshire
Department of Revenue um a quick
summation of of some of the challenges
that those three parties would face on
this move
um and the fifth one uh again
re-emphasizing uh the revenue impact
good or bad um of a move to worldwide
combined reporting on the
state
okay and and uh I think that's a good
succinct list of the five primary
reasons as I think about it more during
the week I might want to flush a couple
of those out a little further
yes makes
sense
okay
um I just want to thank you both again I
think this is a very very
valuable structure and approach for
organizing uh the information in a
neutral fashion thank you any other
questions okay
so we
have
mostly a you know it's it's not a
finished product but but we have in
front of us The Narrative of the
testimony and The Narrative of the uh
generally accepted
considerations um the potential
mitigating factors the pros and the
cons how much
analysis or explanation do we think this
report needs to have before it leaps to
a
recommendation I have a feeling that
even for myself in answering my own
question I practically have to sit at a
computer and see what flows off the
fingers as I try to make sure that you
know we've really
addressed everything that we need
to so but the answer to my question may
also depend on whether you've come down
with a firm conclusion or whether you're
in a more
equivocal um stance
anybody want to H how much analysis
before we just leap to a
recommendation or does this pretty much
lay it
out Mr chairman I can speak for myself I
mean I'm I'm on a very firm conclusion I
know where I stand on the issue and I
have to say that I've served on several
of these over my years in the
legislature this has been the most
thoroughly um uh talked about hammered
out batted around proposal I've ever or
consideration I've ever T had had a
privilege to sit upon you've done a very
thorough job of looking at the issue um
but I I know where I stand and I I think
we have a
consensus
so okay thank
you
others I I think the the answer that
that question is just it depends on if
if if you're stepping in as a an outside
reader and would all the content of the
uh
report um support the the
recommendations that's being laid out
and if the answer is yes then I don't
think there's any any need for any
additional analysis or any uh to be
Implement to be incorporated into the
report uh but if if you think that once
you're reading it um
as an outside reader they say okay yeah
somehow the uh the findings or the uh
the presentations of of the context
somehow this doesn't connect with the
recommendation then maybe some some
links some bridges might need to be
built in that sense um I I mean it's
probably a bit challenging for us
because we've been in this commission um
and so we've seen it um all
internally um I I would think it I think
it's we have enough I do think so but um
I I think if maybe a neutral party if
they would read it I'm not sure they
might also have the same conclusion but
it's just something that I'm I'm
bringing up to to to your attention
that's
all okay thank you and uh staying
neutral consistently can be
challenging any other thought
Mr
Kennedy so
um I think again largely staying neutral
and neutral being that conceptually I
understand the idea of the transfer
pricing issue and Mr Schamberg's um
position that there is this perceived
idea of an unlevel playing field and I
don't think anybody really wants to
would want to leave thinking yes we've
agreed there's an unlevel playing field
but we're going to leave it as it is
anyway I think that the information
provided simply um is insufficient to
determine that that actually exists and
because of that comp
um going
along with that and considering the
complications to move to an alternative
method to move to worldwide reporting
that that um there's there just isn't
enough available to us relative to
making a change of this
magnitude and
that if the desire is to potentially
move to worldwide reporting and to level
the playing field because it's perceived
that it exists that steps would need to
be taken in order to better
quantify well what is the unle does a
unlevel playing field exist and I don't
think that that information is available
and I think the Dr or something would
need to be done to collect information
to determine well how do we quantify
that U which would certainly be I
imagine a significant burden on the on
the Dr as well but I think without um
enough information the the burden of
moving to a change um it just isn't
supported I I agree with you um and you
don't have to become an advocate for a
different
alternative to get to the point of
concluding that this particular approach
is not a good idea un unwise on balance
you
know um Mr Foley want to add
anything um not not a ton I I think your
question is how expansive does the
report have to be at its core and um I
guess having not read many of these in
my life we've had a 90 pager that's been
provided to us in a seven pager I think
right and kind of I know which one I
opted for um and so I I you know I
somewhat defer to you as as primary
drafter of this on what level of context
it's all there how much color do you
want to provide to help someone get to
it is really uh the question I think the
core stuff we've framed uh there is an
impassioned Minority Report um that does
have to be IGN knowledged in some sense
right so um but yeah I don't I don't
know beyond that okay that's uh very
good as I said I I don't suggest in any
way that we tamper with or put pressure
on The Minority
Report
um I'll have another comment about that
in a moment uh representative ly is
there anything that you want to add
no no and keeping the minority report
them um that that is the sole arthor
authorship of Representative shamberg is
a good idea he does have strongly held
and I can understand where they're
coming from I disagree with them but I
understand where they're coming from and
what he's attempting to do I just don't
think this is the vehicle to do it okay
very fair um so with that in
mind because we do have an articulated
passionate
um Minority Report there's at least a
temptation to want to have a
full-throated rebuttal I think we should
resist that
temptation but what I'm thinking is this
um I think that uh the final
recommendation should be very succinctly
stated so I'm going to draft a brief
interlude that I'll call majority analys
is just to
summarize um what the key points are
driving us to disagree that worldwide
combined reporting should be implemented
by the state of New Hampshire at this
time that might include there's
insufficient evidence it's too radical a
change it creates administrative burdens
both for the Filer and for the uh Tax
Administration brief but just to pull
together that these are the
conclusions of the majority and take it
beyond what was I think quite well done
and deliberately a neutral set of
statements in the findings okay not
argumentative not a rebuttal but a
succinct statement of why we disagree in
going
forward I'll hold till next Monday to
ask whether everybody uh is
comfortable uh signing on to that report
I would hope that all six of us would be
in a position to sign on to it but
you'll speak next
Monday and I'd rather have a draft in
front of you that you can subtract from
than to not have a
draft okay
good anything further that advances the
mission this
morning all right well thank you very
much and again thank you drafters that
was excellent you've done something I
wasn't prepared to do in in in that
degree at
all okay that concludes the meeting and
the commission is
adjourned